les amériques alors l'idée de faire le
voyage à travers les amériques et en
moto en plus à ce moment commencé
environ 14 ans j'étais un peu plus jeune
10 ans et j'avais écouté le canal royal
qui raconter l'histoire de naftogaz
heurts entre jeunes et qui a fait un
voyage à moto au total le site de la
mairie
et si un rythme toujours un peu mal
fasciné et j'ai toujours rêvé de faire
ça
et donc j'ai décidé éventuellement
montaut de faire un voyage séminaire
c'est surtout animé pas ma curiosité
envers des amériques mais des peuples
d'amérique les trente personnes à
travers le continent et un sentiment que
à l'intérieur de mon identité de
québécois de canadiens y avait un autre
un autre niveau identitaire et
continental que je connaissais peu et
que j'avais besoin de découvrir